في باكستان تجمع حشد من مؤيد حزب انصاف
زعامه الرئيس الحكومه السابقه عمران خان
في مدينه
المحاديه للعاصمه اسلام اباد لدعوه الحزب
الذي يطالب بتنظيم الانتخابات العامه
مبكرا في المقابل دعت الحكومه حسب انصاف
الى الغاء التجمر لانه بلا هدف بحسب وزير
الداخليه الذي اكده وجود مخاطر امنيه
وردتها تقارير اجهزه المخابرات كما رفضت
الحكومه الرضوخه لمطلبه تنظيم الانتخابات
مبكرا
هذا وقلنا عمران خان زعيم حزب انصاف رئيس
الحكومه الباكستانيه المقال عن حل
الحكومتين المحليتين في اقليم خيبر
والفنجان وسقاله كل نواب حسبه من
البرلمانيين المحليين وفي كلمه القاها
امام حشد من اتباعه في مدينه روى الفندق
اعلن او اكد عمران خان رفضه البقاء في ظل
حكومه فاسده حسب قوله
البرلمانات المحليه في الاقاليم وسنعقد
لاحقا اجتماعا لتحديد موعد استقاله وبناء
من تلك البرلمانات اذ لا نريد ان نكون
جزءا من النظام الحالي الفاسد